mg 1 9 7 4 et un moyen de communication
mises à la disposition de la jeunesse
c'est un nouveau média donc qui existent
donc sur sur internet
donc c'est un projet effectivement pour
les jeunes qui sont à la réunion mais
aussi pour les jeunes qui sont de
passage
donc ça veut dire que les jeunes qui
sont à la réunion donc ils peuvent faire
connaître leur art ils faire connaître
leur identité
je dirai à la planète entière en rose
sur toute la toile moi je suis des deux
associés et temps dans la technique donc
je m'occupe principalement du site à tf1
doute la partie technique alors que mon
associé dont carrie donc s'occupe de
toute la partie production commerciale
communication le point fort du projet
dans qu'est la sécurisation des
activités dans par des modérateurs qui
sont qui sont en forme et la
participation des adultes qui gravitent
autour des jeunes donc à savoir par
exemple des associations comme bon
l'association de la lutte contre
l'illettrisme et d'autres types
d'associations et surtout la
coparticipation dont des enfants fin des
jeunes à la montée en puissance du
cinéma d'ici
le point principal pour les challenges
masse et c'est la notoriété et puisque
le maximum de jeunes viennent vers nous
et qu'ils comprennent que c'est que
c'est leur leurs outils de demain leurs
moyens de communication pour pour pour
s'épanouir à l'avenir donc avec
christian nous sommes à une croisée de
chemins avec comme point commun d'avoir
passé une trentaine d'années hors
département aujourd'hui nous souhaitons
partager cette riche expérience à la
jeunesse dans leur éducation dans leurs
informations ils dans leur formation
christian mérite de gagner est porteur
d'un projet pays et puis surtout il co
construit ce projet avec les très bonnes
idées des jeunes est accompagnée
également des parents
mon parcours professionnel avant cette
aventure dont une trentaine d'années à
l'extérieur de la réunion donc en
métropole et en europe donc en qualité
d'ingénieur donc j'ai eu une riche
expérience professionnelle dans le
domaine des technologies de
l'information de la communication
j'avais décidé de de possibles ma
carrière donc à la réunion donc et
surtout j'avais envie de m'investir
profit de profit de ville et au profit
des enfants
j'ai deux enfants dont qui m'ont soutenu
et surtout comme il s'agissait d'un
projet pour des jeunes dont ils étaient
les premiers fanas de me voir me lancer
dans cette descente aventure au profit
des jeunes que la part dans l'entreprise
dans ma vie privée je dirais que c'est
du fifty fifty
donc je participe
je suis dans l'est dans les deux
domaines christian est vraiment
quelqu'un de fiable en en qui j'ai une
entière confiance qui va vraiment au
bout de ce qu'il entreprend et d'une
très grande rigueur
je me souviens très bien on a déjeuné
ensemble et il m'a dit ah il faut
absolument que te parle d'un projet il
était vraiment super motivé et j'ai
vraiment senti une nouvelle énergie chez
lui et en tant qu'ami je dis bah oui
vas-y foncé et si tu as besoin de te
suis
je suis fier d'être d'être là d'être
tête d'être associé à la joie d'être
parmi les 12 finalistes et je suis sûr
que si on arrive à être dans le peloton
de tête sont les jeunes qui vont en
profiter de sa participer au prix du
public
voter pour votre candidat favori
jusqu'au 27 novembre sur www.cc 9 7 4
points faire et la page facebook
challenge des créateurs
ouais